hey everyone welcome to this session by
simply learn
in today's session we'll learn all about
selenium
but before we proceed make sure to hit
the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
now let's jump in and see what's in
store for us first
we'll look at what manual testing is and
some of its drawbacks
after that we'll understand the need for
automation testing
and what selenium is we'll also learn
about selenium suite of tools
we'll understand the advantages and
limitations of selenium testing
and lastly we look at selenium jobs and
salaries
and finally how simply learn can help
you so moving on
what exactly is manual testing well back
in the early 2000s
testing was mainly done manually it
involved the physical execution of test
cases
against various applications to detect
bugs and errors
it required the knowledge of a testing
tool
over time this process came with a lot
of challenges
it proved to be extremely time consuming
it posed a high risk of error it
required the presence of a tester
throughout
it had a limited scope and there was no
support for performance and batch
testing
now considering all these drawbacks a
desperate need to automate the testing
process was in demand
jason huggins an engineer at
thoughtworks bugged with a strenuous job
decided to try and automate this process
he developed a javascript program called
the javascript test runner
although initially it was only deployed
by the employees at thoughtworks
it was later renamed as selenium and was
made open source
since its inception selenium has been a
powerful automation testing tool
to test various web applications
now what exactly is selenium selenium is
an automation testing tool
used to test web applications across
various browsers
now it can only test web applications
and requires other tools to test
desktop and mobile applications well
that's a bummer huh
now let's look at some of its features
it is open source
it consists of a dedicated set of tools
which we'll discuss shortly
it is primarily developed in javascript
it provides a record and play feature
without having to learn any scripting
language
it can also be coded in several
programming languages
it is a browser and a platform
independent tool meaning it can run
on multiple browsers like chrome safari
firefox
to name a few and on multiple operating
systems like windows mac os or even
linux now let's go ahead and look at the
selenium suite of tools
the first tool is selenium ide selenium
integrated development environment
was developed by shunya kasatani back in
2006.
it was both a firefox and a chrome
extension that can automate the browser
functionality
it comes with a record and play feature
that records the user interactions
and exports them as a reusable script
now when executed it plays the recorded
actions
any deviation in the result indicates
the presence of a bug
coming to the script generated it can be
modified using selenius commands
like actions accessors and even
assertions
you could check out the detailed
tutorial for ide in the description box
the link is mentioned now selenium
ide can be deployed on different
platforms like mac os
linux and even windows ide ceased to
exist back in 2017
when firefox released its firefox 55
version
a robust and revamped version was
released by aptly tools in 2018.
now this new interface came with a
selenium side runner that allowed all
ide tests to run
parallely on multiple browsers
now let's look at the typical interface
and understand its components
first up on the top we have the menu bar
now here you can either create a new
project
or open an existing project or even save
a project
after that we have the toolbar we can
run all the tests if in case we have
multiple test cases
next to that we have a button to help
run the current test
id also has the debugger option use foot
step execution
and then you can also regulate the speed
of execution using the feature
next up we have the start and stop
recording feature
now this icon as the name suggests helps
to record the test case
next we have the address bar now this
basically shows the url of the
application under test
moving on we have the test script editor
box this is where all the
script tests are recorded now it has
four attributes first up we have the
command
which indicates the actions performed on
the web elements
then we have a target now this indicates
the element on which the action is being
performed
and finally we have a value now this is
an optional field
we can send values to various web
elements on the browser
next up we have the test case pane now
this basically consists of all the test
cases that have been recorded up to date
finally we have the test login reference
now this is a running log as where as in
when your test script runs the id will
log it here
it indicates if the command was run
successfully or not
we also have a reference tag that will
show the complete description of
commands and how to use them
now let me show you a quick demo on how
ide really works
in the beginning you'll have to install
the ide
plugin so you can basically go to google
and say selenium id plugin
click on the first link
and you can see add to chrome however
it's added in mine
so i'll just leave it to that moving on
let's go ahead and click on the icon
here to the top right corner
now this is what the typical id looks
like so let's go ahead and record a new
test
in a new project and let me call the
project name
amazon underscore books
so now it requires the website url on
which we are going to be testing
so in our case we're using amazon so
let's go to the
amazon website let's copy its url
paste it here and then say start
recording now once i
click on start recording it's going to
record all my user actions
so let's go ahead
so i'd wish to look at today's deals so
i go ahead and click on today's deals
after that say i'm interested in looking
at books so i go ahead and click on
books here
after that i wish to click on say the
fourth book here i say add to cart
so i click on that
after that let's go ahead and check out
here we go the book has been added once
i'm done with that i'll close my browser
and stop recording here
let's call it books
for now so here
all the commands have been logged and as
you can see once i
click on the play button it's going to
display
all the recorded commands so let's go
ahead and click on that
but before that let me reduce the text
execution speed
so that it's easier for you to see
and now i say play
so as you can see all the commands are
turning green indicating that all the
steps have been performed successfully
so here you go it goes to books
and that is it well it was a little fast
however all our commands have been
successfully executed
finally a message is displayed saying
completed successfully
so this is a small example of how to
show you how ide works
so going back let's go ahead and look at
the next
tool next up we have
selenium remote control
rc was developed by paul hammond and is
a server written in java
rc makes provision for writing
application tests in various programming
languages
b c sharp perl php python etc
the rc server accepts commands from the
user program
and passes them to the browser as
selenium core javascript
commands now consider a typical
javascript program say
test.js used by google.com now the
program can access pages within the
google.com
domain like google.com mail or login
however it cannot access elements of
other domains like yahoo.com
so local copies of selenium core and the
web browser
have to be installed so that they belong
to the same domains
the server acts as a client configured
http proxy
and tricks the browser into believing
that selenium core and the web
application being tested came from the
same origin
that's pretty cool huh well moving on
let's look at the next tool in the suite
we have the selenium webdriver it was
developed by simon stevert and web
driver revolutionized automation testing
it was the first cross cross platform
testing framework
that provided the interface to create
and run test cases
webdriver allows the users to perform
actions like click or hover on web
elements
again the scripts can be written in any
programming language
beat perl php java etc it also supports
frameworks like test ng or junit for
test management
but the main usp of webdriver is that
unlike
rc it doesn't require a core engine and
interacts with the browser natively
to learn more about webdriver there's a
link in the description box
make sure to click on that to get a
better understanding
and the final tool is the selenium grid
now it was developed by patrick
lightbody
the main objective of grid was to
minimize the test execution speed grid
was designed to distribute commands to
different machines
simultaneously it is exceptionally
flexible
and can be integrated with other tools
the typical setup of a grid consists of
a central hub connected to several
machines
the hub receives the test to be executed
along with the information
about the os and the browser to be run
on
now the hub accordingly picks one of the
machines that conforms to the
requirements
later it delegates the tasks
so with that we've come to the end of
selenium suite components
now let's look at the advantages of
selenium testing
first up we have speed and accuracy the
testing process is quick
and accurate since any human errors are
ruled out
it is also open source meaning anybody
can download and start working on small
projects
and as we've discussed earlier it
supports a wide range of programming
languages and operating systems
it is also very easy to ex to implement
it doesn't require a strong knowledge
about the tool and lastly the main
advantage is the fact that it is
reusable
moving on let's look at the
disadvantages of selenium testing
since it does not have a central body
governing its working
selenium does not have a reliable tech
support
it can only test web applications
selenium also fails with image testing
it doesn't provide an inbuilt reporting
facility and has to be integrated with
third party tools
some of these tools could be test ng or
junit
they also help with test management and
while using
webdriver the user is expected to have a
fair knowledge of the
programming language used moving on
let's look at the selenium jobs and
salaries
now here are some of the rules performed
by test engineers
first up the employee is expected to
develop test cases and detect
bugs and errors to design the full
framework for implementation
to ensure the better best communication
practices
to define test strategies for fixing
software issues
so these are some of the key roles of a
test engineer
moving on to the salaries according to
pay scale
the average salary of an automation
engineer in the u.s is a whopping 90
000 us dollars per annum the average
salary of an automation engineer in
india
is around 5 lakhs 24 000 rupees per
annum
now let's look at the top tier companies
that deploy selenium
some of these companies are google
emphasis tcs
capgemini among others so now you must
be wondering
how simply learn could help you if
you're looking to make a career as a
test engineer
then i'd recommend you go to some of the
courses offered by us
so let's go to our official website
you could visit our official website and
look up
for the course that you want i'll say
selenium
training
now you get a few options and depending
on your requirement
you can take up the appropriate course
we have automation testing masters
program
we have a selenium 3.0 training program
and we have javascript certification
training
now you can click on one of these
programs
get a brief overview and some of its key
features
so finally let's look at the key
takeaways now what did we learn
so first we understood the shortcomings
of manual testing
and why test automation was actually
necessary
then we understood what selenium is and
some of its key
salient features then to answer the
question as to why selenium is so
efficient
we learned about its robust suite of
tools
finally we understood some of its
advantages
and every tool comes with its set with
its set of disadvantages
so we learned about some of the
limitations and finally
we spoke about the scope of selenium so
with that
we've reached the end of this session i
hope you guys found this informative and
helpful
thank you for watching keep learning and
stay tuned to simply learn
also make sure to subscribe and hit the
bell icon
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here